this is a story from all things
interesting everything you ever wanted
to know about what happens when you die
obvious well what will hold on let's
read it how do they know
well maybe see you're jumping the gun I
am judge a book by its cover
I am Jim and the first sentence no
living human knows what happens when we
die um see but here's what we've gleaned
from history and some near-death
survivors who said they glimpsed the
other side first of all they assume
there is another side they think that
they viewed something all right
let's uh let's uh let's say no way I'm
letting my judgment flow all that's
interesting says what happens when you
dies perhaps one of the greatest
mysteries on earth simply because none
of us know the answer and yet all of us
will experience death eventually wait
really what I'm joking
good humankind's great thinkers have
been pondering this question for
millennia and in 1994 an orthopedic
surgeon named Tony Chick Corea may have
come close to solving this great mystery
when he was struck by a nearly fatal
bolt of lightning in upstate New York
Sakura chick oriano jacory afem self fly
backwards and the next thing he
remembered was turning around to see his
body lying on the ground behind him for
a moment jacory reported he stood there
and watched a woman perform CPR on his
body before he floated up a flight of
stairs to watch his children play in
their rooms then I was surrounded by a
bluish white light an enormous feeling
of well-being in peace the highest and
lowest points of my life raced by me I
had the perception of accelerating being
drawn up then as I was saying to myself
this is the most glorious feeling I've
ever had
slam that was back according to dr. Pam
pornea who has studied near-death
experiences for years Cora's encounter
was not an uncommon one death is a
process it is not a black and white
moment in recent years doctors like
pornea and close call survivors like chi
Korea have helped deepen humanity's
understanding of what happens when we
die so let's let's pause for a second
and let me ask do you think that what
these people are experiencing is just
some kind of reaction in their minds
like DMT or something absolutely that's
exactly what you think that's what I've
been thinking nope no possibility
thought there was actually a spirit an
energy because you know when you die you
lose
a bit of weight right is that true I
think we talked about this right it's
actually not it's not true miss someone
like someone said it and we kind of
looked it up and I don't think it's true
yeah it was a moment's research but
every single animal plant living thing
has DMT in it and when we die when any
animal dies the DMT gets released so
this person almost died the brain
released the DMT tripping yeah I had a
DMT trip so I'm assuming because it it
was it seemed like he was gonna go to
like what he perceived as heaven right
he believed that he was he believed that
he mean I'm assuming right now you know
but it felt like obviously went to his
kids he's he all his life flashed before
his eyes because who knows what a large
amount of DMT into your brain does I've
never done it but I know people do do it
I mean the people who've done large
doses probably can tell you true that's
true and they say they've gone to
another world another world places crazy
stuff you know and it's like hmm what a
surprise it's probably what they believe
yeah because I think it amplifies what
you believe it because it it sends it to
your whole brain so like it's like your
brain gets supercharged while the rest
of you dies and then you go underwater
wherever you believe like what's the
evolutionary advantage of something that
happens when you die it's a good point
yeah well let's uh let's read more what
science says about what happens when you
die while we may not fully understand
the feeling of dying until we experience
it for ourselves we do know what happens
to our bodies right before and after
death at first according to dr. nina
o'connor a person's breathing will
become irregular and unusually shallow
or deep their breath can then begin to
sound like a rattle or a gurgle which
happens because the person isn't able to
cough up or swallow secretions in their
chest and throat all of it comes from
the process of the body slowing and
shutting down she says this sound has
been fittingly called the death rattle
then at the moment of death every muscle
in the body relaxes this may cause the
person to moan or sigh as any excess air
is released from their lungs and into
their throat and vocal cords meanwhile
as the body relaxes the pupils dilate
the jaw may fall
and the skin sags if the person has any
urine or feces in their body these will
be released too but as parney is
suggested death doesn't happen in an
instant and some researchers assert that
our brains can operate up to 10 minutes
after our heart stops beating within the
first hour after death the my god the
body begins to experience the death
chill or Algor mortis is when the corpse
cools from its normal temperature to the
temperature of the room around it
after a couple of hours blood will begin
to pool in the areas of the body that
are closer to the ground due to gravity
this is known as liver mortis
if the body stays in the same position
for several hours these body parts will
start to look bruised while the rest of
the body grows pale limbs and joints
will then begin to stiffen within a few
hours after death during a process
called rigor mortis when the body is at
its maximum stiffness the knees and
elbows will be flexed and the fingers
and toes might appear crooked but after
around 12 hours the process of rigor
mortis will start to reverse this is due
to the decay of internal tissue and it
lasts between one and three days during
this reversal the skin begins to tighten
and shrink which can create the illusion
the person's hair nails and teeth have
grown the skin tightening is also
responsible for the illusion that blood
has been sucked from the corpses which
in turn inspired some of the vampire
legends of me to medieval Europe that we
still know today so that's all the
physical stuff right what physicians say
it feels like when we die do we want to
do I want to go through the physical
stuff where we want to go to the crazy
stuff no yeah I don't I don't like what
does it feel like I mean that was still
kind of interesting I didn't know any
that stuff I don't know if anyone else
that I've seen I didn't know there was
three this is mortises but neither I
know about rigor mortis but livor mortis
and what's the other one the first one
rigor mortis Algor mortis that's what
really happens after you die from people
who have been there oh look at this dr.
Oz talked to who's dr. Sam Parr Nia
setting aside what happens to the
deceased body after they die what
happens to them to their very being in
their soul while the world's cultures
and religions can offer some possible
answers
so can survivors of near-death
experiences in 1988 actress Jane Seymour
went into anaphylactic shock as her body
began to shut down her mind state aware
I had the vision of seeing a white light
and looking down and seeing myself in
this bedroom with a nurse frantically
trying to save my life and jabbing
injections into me and I'm calmly
watching this whole thing she said
describing a scene common in reports
from those who have almost died but I'm
gonna stop there - I wonder if these
people were already exposed to that idea
like you were saying exactly if you're
told this is what happens and then you
have a near-death experience
you're sure set up for this so when you
start tripping because DMT makes you
trip that what do you think is there
gonna visit you know see they're gonna
their brain their body's shutting down
their brain goes okay we're about to die
inject the DMT into the into the brain
so we can get that and then your brain
knows you're not freaking out that
you're dying you're like oh okay I'm
dying
all right that's kind of interesting and
the guy at the first was talking about
seeing the high points and low points of
his life and then going to floating up
to see his kids so that's like seeing
your life flash flash but is it possible
that these tropes have merged because
some people yeah right what caused it
which caused it which is the effect like
yeah I want to know if it's if it's the
DMT or are they because if their brain
is still alive in their awake for up to
10 minutes and that means there's
they're not dead they're not gone and
left their body you know right because
if they it once the brain dies that's it
they can't you can't come back after
that right is that yeah that's what
about people when the brain is fully
dead you're like okay there so but it
should be simple that too if they
described seeing someone doing some of
their body mm-hmm and they come back
that was what was done well so here's
what I mean like he she said that she
was you know looking down seeing a nurse
jab her then coach she described the
back of the nurses head did she was it
was it discussed you know it should be
or or did did she was she awake and she
saw the nurse before she knew what the
nurse looked like and she her brain can
add the piece that's why I'm set and
imagine the rest of it because she's
tripping we need to do tests where we
have like a number on someone's back and
when they're working at a hospital no
for real yeah they should do this as
part of a research like give well the
army was doing that they are actually no
it was the air
force because you know the G the G
machine that ret registers how much G's
you can do well people were passing out
and then they were claiming exactly the
same thing they were having near-death
experiences and it's because what was
happening the blood was leaving their
brain the brain was like oh or we don't
have any blood we're dying shot of DMT
into the brain and they're like oh
interesting these these near-death
experiences all these pilots were having
were the same thing they were they were
seeing themselves so put somebody in in
a suit with a spade a club a star or
whatever and then when someone's like I
looked down and saw a man was on his
back it was I don't know there was
nothing well he's got a symbol there and
you were wrong there you go well sure
let's let's go more specific but three a
little bit more of this yeah dr. Sam
Varney recorded this phenomenon with
multiple survivors during his 2014 study
of near-death experiences one patient
could recall what was happening in the
hospital for a full three minutes after
his heart stopped the man described
everything that happened in the room but
importantly he heard two bleeps from
machine that makes a noise at three
minute intervals so we could time how
long the experience lasted for he seemed
very credible and everything that he
said had happened to him had actually
happened yes but he's literally in the
room like dude if you're laying on a
table you're like I'm then I the man
said this like right you were there
you're like but his your hearing is
still alive right just it we just read
that the heart can stop and for 10
minutes the brain could still be alive
so the ears are here the brain is here
well who's to say and actually it
doesn't
ears don't need to hear the sound they
can feel the vibration of sound and
that's like there's some headphones that
just do vibrations straight into your
brain they're quoting Duchin yeah yeah
yeah yeah like say that that's what he
was hearing right there Zoey kurz so
here's what happens he's hearing all
this have you ever fallen asleep with
the TV on
yeah and then you have a dream kind of
about what was on the TV yeah did it
happen to me and scooby-doo way too much
because I'd be watching Adult Swim and
it would be like you know family guy or
something and then all of a sudden had
this crazy dream where I was like on a
scooby-doo mystery and I would be like
running through a factory with with
Scooby and Shaggy like the craziest
dreams yeah and then I would I would
snap to I'm like
I left the TV on again and fell asleep
you know like I'd be in my dream and
wake and like and realize it and then
I'd slowly wake up and I turn the TV off
like the scooby-doo was playing in my
ears influencing my dreams it was like
before they say to listen to stuff to
learn it while you're sleeping yeah
now the thing about this guy he already
saw the room did help did he he knew
well maybe no maybe not I don't know it
doesn't say it does it good see one one
patient they don't didn't explain it so
it doesn't even say it but a hole hold
on if I'm just me jumping to making
assumptions I guess but it's like there
still isn't enough details for me to go
okay well what I'm thinking is wrong
because there isn't enough it's always
like well we talked to them where I know
a week after it happened and they talked
told us all about what they remembered I
think they're in the room mm-hmm and
they're hearing things and their brain
is creating an image of what they think
is happening right so clearly just there
it's a it's soaked in DMT I know it's
not even about the damn you necessarily
it's just like you're dreaming well
there's your people say things and
you're at your you're visualizing it
like when I dream about astral
projecting into Scooby land yeah but a
TV on but if I closed my eyes right now
and I just kept my eyes closed and you
started talking I can see you talking
right I can see this room you know I can
hear the air conditioning just turned on
and I can like you know it's like if I
was my heart stopped and my brain was
still functioning I bet this is what I
would see in here well it's real it more
he says well not every survivor that
parney has spoke with had an out-of-body
experience as many as 40% of them do
recall having some sort of awareness
when they were declared clinically dead
even after flatlining many survivors
were called seeing a bright welcoming
light or their deceased relatives or the
doctors and nurses working on them in
the hospital what's more many of them
who experienced consciousness after
death remember not wanting to return to
their bodies
oh man that's yeah yeah that's why
everyone loves tripping so much yeah
right however many scientists remains
skeptical of those reports and attribute
them to everything from lucid dreaming
to a lack of oxygen in the brain hey can
you trip more while more research needs
to be done before we know for sure what
happens when we die perhaps it is at
least comforting to
think that our consciousness floats on
as our bodies expire for at least 10
minutes on here for at least 10 minutes
so look I'm not gonna pretend like you
know they I think it was really cool
they went through the basic functions of
what happens when you actually die
mm-hmm but I gotta say men I wanted more
well no no I I did I I'm a little
disappointed I mean no no I think it's
awesome I knew this is this was gonna be
exactly what it was
so here's what's great good we talked
about it here's the problem this doesn't
happen all the time and it's very very
hard to pin down exactly what the heck
is going on because like you're talking
about in my pee DMT might be like of
oxygen like Tim is talking you it could
be that also dreaming it could be that
also yeah you could be all of this you
hallucinate when you get low on oxygen
or what if everybody has a different
body and I might have like a massive
pack of DMT in my brain yes you've got a
little bit so when you dies to almost
die you get a little tiny bit of DMT
right how are you supposed to do a
scientific study of this when it doesn't
even happen all the time
yeah really hard and who's to say is
like diet put symbols on ovals back
general hell okay real it might make a
difference listen in all of this you
know we do you know universities can go
the the researchers can go to various
hospitals and say here are some scrubs
with some symbols on it
doesn't matter what you wear when you
wear it right yeah just wear them yeah
and that way if anyone at any point says
I had an experience what was on doctor
you know Kensington's back anyone's back
and right did they see it before they
had the experience like when they were
conscious cuz I think that makes it if
somebody is rushed into an emergency
room unconscious Oh getting out right
it's saved and they say I I died but I
experienced everything it's like okay
there was a woman do you know her name
someone said it was dr. Linda that's
right that was her name people were
yelling dr. Linda please do this yeah
now what color was her clothes blue well
yes all of the doctors are wearing blue
scrubs congratulations
what was the symbol we placed on her
back I don't know so what is the
attraction of saying that this happened
to you when it didn't know no Fame
no no I think people are very instead
yeah I think I really don't think it's
it's a cry for attention I think they're
they're having a trip I think
they're going on a mental trip and I
think it is a combination of all of the
things lucid dreaming lack of oxygen the
dmg thing it's like all of these things
play a part as well as their health and
their weight you know if you're
overweight it probably won't affect you
as much you know yeah I mean I'm
speculating well it's like if it takes
more to get high when you weigh more
than yeah exactly precisely affects men
and women differently right why do you
think it's sad tomb that there's nothing
if the reality is just well saw their
dead relatives - right they probably
already thought in life that when I die
I'm gonna see my relatives again the
ones they wanted to slay did they know
they were dying do they know their
brains there that's what the brains are
when it's dying here's what I'm saying
about why it's sad don't you know would
it be more exciting if there was more to
reality and more to existence you know
just like where my bag attention we're
gone higher dimension and maybe I'll
talk about maybe maybe they're they're
passing off into a different dimension
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you